افغانستان
الكثير من الناس المحتاجين هناك الكثير من
الالام المتفرقه وللاسباب المتفرقه كيف
تتعاملون مع شان
الافغانيستان
هي بلد
تعاملنا في مع الكثير من الازمات منذ
منتصف الثمانينات فالمحزن ان نقول اننا
نقدم ونوفر الحمايه لاجيال من الافغان
واحيانا نرى الاجداد الذين نقدم لهم
المساعده بعد تقديم المساعده
لابنائهم واحفادهم فهؤلاء اجيال من
الافغان يحصلون على المساعدات والوضع
الاقتصادي يتهاوى وما
ركزنا عليه منذ شهر اغسطس من عام 2021
فقد دعمنا حوالي ثلاثين مستشفى في
افغانستان من خلال تقديم رواتب
دكاتره والاطباء والممرضين ونواصل القيام
بذلك لان هذا امر حيوي بالنسبه للافغان
وكذلك يشمل عملنا
عمل اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر
زياره السجناء ونواصل القيام بذلك كما
اننا نحاول بدل قصار جهدنا لتوفير سبل
العيش فان اجيال تعول على المساعدات
الانسانيه من
اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر فلدينا
مبادره اقتصاديه تدعم الاشخاص للحصول على
سبل العيش الخاصه بهم للحصول ايضا على
كرامتهم هذه هي اولوياتنا ولكن ينبغي ان
اقول ان نقوم بذلك في ظروف بالغه الصعوبه
في افغانستان لكن اننا الملتزمين بمساعده
الافغان